everyone how are you guys doing hope you
guys are having a wonderful day and
today we are here with surprisingly more
merchants so if you if you're new to
this series basically at one point I was
a I was a wee lad starting the cert in
the runescape scene not really been
around for a while but I have five male
on this random account that I got to
have and that we're up 31 but actually
that's a line we're actually up to forty
six point eight ish yeah so we're forty
six point eight as you can see my
ballistics from the last episode have
sold so we're gonna find some new items
and see where we can go from here if you
guys are new feel free to hit that
subscribe button if you guys enjoy the
video make sure to leave the link later
on you know you got to watch enough of
it and if you guys never mind
[__] that [__] that I'm not believing
this clip and if I do I'm a [__]
all right so a little heart-to-heart
here for a second as you guys know these
are merging videos so most of the things
that I do that are typically good items
you guys will see however in some
instances today jr. in some instances
like the item I am merging now I will
not be showing the item itself in the
video I will show the prices at which I
bought them and sold them at however I
will not show the item itself honestly
have no clue I'm on you're trying to
make merging videos and stuff like that
when I can just search that giveaway on
Facebook and win 20 mil like what's the
point these next few episodes [__] it
well
checked out the white ballistas as I
always do and as you can see bought for
5 mil then like ballistas at least the
guy price says they are at 4.7 so
there's 350 or 300 k margins I don't
know why about 350 so 300 k margins I'm
gonna try to buy seven of these
overnight hopefully and so right before
I'm going to bed two of the blisters
have sold however I'm just gonna keeping
this off for overnight and hopefully
they'll buy just woke up it's actually
6:00 a.m. I went to bed at like 2:00 so
I don't know what the [__] I'm doing up
I'm gonna go back to bed
but apparently from what OS buddy says I
have the highest buy price in and it
says that I should be able sell them
from 5.07 mill of three hours later went
back to bed only one of the blazes have
sold which is pretty depressing no more
buts I think I'm just gonna exit the
offer on that I figured over that span
there would at least be more than 300 K
margins one way or another and I'd be
able to buy some or sell some however
apparently not guessed me out under cap
but it's good well little depressing got
back from work and two of these have
sold however no more bought so obviously
the price of them has changed entirely
well I ended up buying these like
ballistas fool
but a four point eight one six sold them
on four four point nine six oh so I made
about 300k nothing too great alright so
basically what you were seeing in this
clip is me going through alright so
basically what you're seeing in this
clip is a bunch of random items I tried
buying overnight hoping that they would
profit in the morning and a little bit
of money however it's nothing too great
and I really probably won't come back to
this but it was worth a shot
alright so a lot of this stuff has sold
off we got some of the dark crabs to
sell on I think someone undercut me but
that's cool we'll go on and sell some
more of those as you can see where we
have 7,000 of these I ended up getting
another 5,000 I think I showed that clip
but insane so I'm gonna take out these
light ballistas we're going to try to
sell these for about 1/6 and I know
around there once we get that we should
be up to probably 41 mil no 40.8 not too
shabby though
alright so here we are I bought a ton of
these things as you can see I have 475
really so we're gonna buy a crystal key
see what it buys for and that's what
we're gonna sell all these on for so it
is bought for thirty-nine nine hundred
and as you can see it cost me two point
eight six and then pretty much nine so
it cost me thirty seven point five
pretty much to make them so one by
putting them together I make two point
four K so if I put all these together I
should make a bow what that's 1.2 mil I
believe alright so disregard how I'm
talking right now I just got back from
the dentist and half my miles [__]
down this [__] but all of the crystal
keys have sold and about 300 have bought
free chaff so we'll put those together
and I'll probably up my Oscar I also got
a ton of these raw dark crabs itself so
that's like alright so I made another
300 pistol keys and as you can see I
bought them for 8.9 K and 28.6 and I'm
going to sell them on 441 so that means
that I made 37.6 oh I made three point
two K per one so I probably made a mill
off of making all those crystal keys
which barely took me any time at all so
I'm gonna buy a ton of these whenever
go to work alright just logged in I'm
gonna check them and not all the crystal
keys sold and none of this stuff Bob
which means the margins have definitely
gone down and I'm gonna have to check
the prices a little bit more log and see
if anything bought overnight you guys
are here with me so anything I see I
will see as well crystal keys some sold
no rock or no raw dark crabs bought
obviously got a ton of dragon bones four
three five one five a ton of red chins
and a kind of raw shark so we're gonna
hopefully make profit on these I'm gonna
see what they are currently buying four
dragon bones as you can see just bought
for three 501 which means I lost 14 GP
and all those pretty [__] depressing
got red chins please please please
please please oh it looks like they
might have made money on that one six
eight four which is really nice so let's
check out these red Chin's real quick so
we bought them for eight point two mil
and we're gonna sell them for one six
eight four correct I believe I believe
that is the price so eight point four
which means we made 300k on the red
chins which is nice so it looks like we
made one GP on the rocks what the [__]
man
alright so I insist sold the loop hats
and almost all of the crystals keys have
sold see if it buys and it should indeed
so 14800 I'm going to try to sell it for
fourteen seven - okay and if it does not
sell it means we have an ADK margin
however it did by 1.5 trade it's [__]
[__] so going to buy some zenite
charge them for fourteen seven to 2k
which would mean that we make 78k on
every one of these that we buy they
bought they bought I finished my game of
beef but I wasn't I forgot about it
totally but I'm gonna sell them on now
for fourteen seven I 9k hopefully they
sell please I always get screwed over on
these so I'm hoping for the best
alright there we go so all the Sunday
charts sold I'm never doing that again
they always suck trying to sell for some
reason they can always buy but they
never do sell which is really annoying
and it sucks for merging but I'm gonna
go on to some different items because
no way I'm doing that ever again all
right it's on the merge account I pretty
much did this thing with tyrannical
reign since there's not a lot of them on
the market I kind of bought up basically
what would be the margin so I bought it
obviously at 5:09 five and I sold it
then four five ten so I knew that I
could buy him at 511 however ebk margin
isn't ideal so I tried this buying up
the price to where I would get 160 K
margin worked
definitely definitely worked but a
problem is none of them bought all right
so just got back from work or treasonous
ring has sold two of our tyrannical
rings are not sold which is no more than
there was previously apparently two
tyrannical rings bought and three light
ballistas which is probably what will
make the most money on this March I
believe
all right so apparently I can sell these
ballistas on for 4.7 mil
if I am able to do that I will make
about 130 K off of each of those which
would be about point for half a mil I
guess all right so overnight as you can
see probably by the chat log all of the
ballistas and tyrannical ranks have sold
however barely any of these rubies
bought which is kind of annoying because
as you can see it's at the prices 881 I
put it in for literally 9 GP higher and
it was not able to buy any at all rubies
are kind of crashed a ton lately which I
don't understand and I kind of want to
take advantage of that and by just
buying a ton of them now however if
people are just yeah see last night
would have been an insane time to buy
them because if you look at that I am
going to be making pretty much what 1
point there I mean like three to four
hundred GP out for each one of those
rubies if I would've bought all these
that would have been an insane merch
however could not buy all of them so it
is what it is all right so I tried to
merge these for some reason light
ballistas right now I'm able to buy for
four male on the dot insta buy I think
three point nine five or yeah just three
point very much for mental on the dot
which means that there's a bigger margin
on light boluses in general I'm probably
just going to buy out these light
ballistas because the price will go up
but I'm going to take advantage of
fact they may be some people willing to
sell them for lower so I'm going to buy
some at this price as well as buy out
the light blisters that are currently at
or under 4.1 mil cuz the price of them
will go back up there's no reason they
should drop like that right now alright
so a little bit different I put in an
offer for a torture ornament kit um I
feel really bad about not getting to
these sooner because they dropped in
nine points three mil at one point which
doesn't make any sense to be totally
honest with you and I knew they would
probably settle around I initially
thought 20 mil ish right now they're at
about sixteen but I feel honestly I
think they will go up right now there's
kind of just a big influx of people
doing clue Scrolls because of the new
items so I bought this for I believe
fifteen point two five fifteen point
three two kinda the same thing um and
we're gonna try to sell it for 15820
we'll see if we can get that that'll be
cool 500k profit I do believe yeah so
we'll see if we can get that then light
blisters I promise you guys I will make
money on I will make money on look at
that actively traded price that just
doesn't make any sense think about it
just think about it for a second with me
so there's no way that will ever be the
price unless monkeytales go down to that
price and monkeytales are 800k more than
that alone so I'm going to just buy out
these light ballistas because I think
that people to make money on it to be
totally honest with you guys
we'll see if I can buy some for this
price cuz I'll buy them I do not care
so we'll see if we can buy some for that
price and flip them for this I don't
know this is definitely stalling my
series though because these are some
long-term flips cuz I'm kind of more
anticipating them going back up and
stuff like that rather than you know
actually being will flip them daily
alright so here we go trading back over
the you saplings that I have made on my
main there we go torture or make it has
sold 500k profit on that we're going to
try and do that again cuz I don't see a
problem and it
all right so I sold off two of the iron
sets for 900k I insist sold them and one
of them have bought instantly for 15 mil
which is not a good sign so I'm going to
drop the offer a little bit to torture
and go for 1485 okay
hope for the best on that one and this
one we're gonna list up for 1565 okay
and here we go ladies and gentlemen this
is where I think I'm going to end off
the video as you can see I invested in
something on this account so there's
some sort of plus I got a little pirates
hat we're going to go and collect the
rest of our stuff from the grand
exchange as you can see all these like
ballistas sold I'm kind of skeptical as
to what price they sold at because I
will be very upset if they sold for like
or if they could have sold for like 4.2
ml actually the buy price is exactly at
this price so it seems as if that is the
price that they were selling it and I
had the highest offer in so that's good
then the port's your ornament kits also
sold right if I sound a little different
it's cuz I just moved my mic anyways the
torch ornament kits also sold for
fifteen point seven mil pretty much that
gets us up to 47 point two and then we
have this iron gold set which I am now
going to try to sell for each 75k I'll
still make about 150 K profit even if I
sell it for that whatever we'll just add
it on to that and so now we are at 58
mil so made a lot of progress this
episode if you guys enjoyed the episode
feel free to leave a like down below
anything you want me to improve on you
can leave that in a comment as well and
yeah if you guys want to see more in the
future be alerted as soon as it goes up
feel free to drop a sub nonetheless hope
you guys have a wonderful day and peace